vuelan puñetazos en el parlamento
[Aplausos]
el caos se tomó momentáneamente el
parlamento de Georgia donde los
legisladores debatían sobre el polémico
proyecto de ley de agentes extranjeros
la bancada del partido dominante el
sueño georgiano lo defiende argumentando
mayor transparencia en la información
para el pueblo
la sociedad merece absolutamente saber
qué organizaciones se financian de qué
fuente y de qué tipo saber cómo ese
dinero se gasta estamos hablando de
responsabilidad y transparencia esta ley
no impone restricción alguna de las
personas
la oposición denuncia que esta nueva
legislación es una copia exacta de la
norma implementada en Rusia en 2012 y
que Moscú no ha cesado de ampliar desde
entonces temen un giro autoritario en el
sistema político la norma obligaría a
las organizaciones que reciben más del
20% de su presupuesto de fuentes
extranjeras a someterse a un monitoreo
cercano por el Ministerio de Justicia
georgiano de lo contrario
enfrentarían graves sanciones económicas
esta nueva propuesta preocupa a un
sector de la sociedad civil del país
vemos esta ley como un desastre para
Georgia porque así es como empezó Rusia
es un grave impedimento para el futuro
europeo de Georgia y llegan un momento
en el que esperamos ser candidatos a la
Unión Europea la gente está enfadada no
quieren que se les llame agentes porque
sirven a su país de buena fe
[Música]
Georgia tiene un pasado complicado en
sus relaciones con Rusia similar al caso
ucraniano la ex repúblicas soviética ha
enfrentado tensiones con Rusia desde la
desintegración del bloque soviético lo
que llevó a un conflicto armado entre
las dos naciones en 2008 ahora Georgia
tiene el deseo de alejarse de su pasado
y acercarse a un futuro europeo
actualmente el país aspira a ingresar a
la Unión Europea